الى نهائي كاس العالم حلقت الارجنتين بعد
فوزها على كرواتيا في هذه المباراه لتكون
اولا من يحجز له ذاك المكان في نهائي كاس
العالم تماما كما انتظر مشجعون الارجنتين
هنا في العاصمه الارجنتينيه هنا سايرس حيث
اتوا
بالالاف الى هنا من مختلف الاعمار الى هذا
المكان وسط العاصمه ليشجع منتخب رافعين
صوره نجمهم ميسي همم مشجعين له في هذه
المباراه الذين يريدون همم من بعدها ان
يحصدوا اللقب كاس العالم الذي انتظروه
طويلا همم هنا معنا بعض المشجعين همم
ارجنتينيه اوكي استاذ
استاذها الى النهائي
[موسيقى]
اهداف لكنه انتصروا واسعدنا
هل تتوقعين ان يحقق المنتخب كاس العالم
نعم سنفوز بكاس العالم
ايضا الذين اتوا الى هنا زي العربي
من مباراه المملكه العربيه السعوديه سابقا
والان الارجنتين تغيرت تماما وانا صلاح
اتمنى انتصار الارجنتين بالمونديال
للامانه اذا هذه هي المشاعر هنا هذه هي
الاجواء وسط العاصمه وهنا صايرز التي
كانوا يتمنوها ان تتاهل الارجنتين وان
تكون هي من نصيبها كاس العالم قطر 2022
حسمود الجزيره من نصايبريس
[موسيقى]